[Music]
in horrible parenting news
oh no hollyball submitted by hi everyone
hello I know buddy
a woman shares your story of having
serial killers as parents oh that must
be an interesting childhood really
interesting both - how did you how did
you get both how did one say you're
gonna meet another one there's you see
there's someone for everyone out there
so don't lose hope you guys killed Bob
last night like a like a killer for more
like a [ __ ] killed thanks for that
movie psycho dude it's like this [ __ ]
Dexter you guys watch Dexter oh yeah I
like Dexter was so funny how on that
show if a little kid witnesses a murder
we know he's gonna become a serial
killer now like they did that several
times he's gotta be a silver killer what
the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
did he meet a girl that oh yeah exactly
mind murders alright so anyway this
story is about Mae West she is a
daughter of Kanye West then call Mae
West know of - she's not enough to
include with serial killers and she's
releasing a book detailing her childhood
so she previously ruled called inside 25
Cromwell Street in the late 90s but now
she's having another book called love as
always mom or mum xxx
so her parents are Fred and Rose West
they were arrested in 1994 Fred hung
himself shortly after confessing to
dozens of murders and himself Rose she
was convicted of 10 but she has never
admitted a thing as of right now she is
still in prison and she is kept separate
from the other prisoners because they
all want to kill her whoa whoa kids
that's why there were some of her
victims routines including their own
daughter Heather they killed another
daughter they killed they killed some
random teens and think of their own hurt
their own daughter
yeah they not gonna be like May so much
huh I never said that
so they had about eight kids also they
were like we could be all dead
I just know that heather was one of the
victims Oh
so um when they say parents don't have
favorites that's a clear example of
favorites thank you no because all of
their children they were abused that one
was abused less how do you know this
because one didn't die yeah a bunch
didn't die yep it was just one that died
yeah that was the least favorite one yep
all right so she I mean so may is saying
how her parents would let her dress up
in the clothes of the victim she knows
what she said quote one day when I was
about 8 we discovered a cupboard full of
women's clothes and shoes Heather and I
used to dress up in them and mom didn't
seem to mind only much later did I
realize that they were the clothes of
young women who had been murdered in the
house because all of their wood all of
the all of their victims were women and
so oh man that's so crazy
like how did did they grow up witnessing
this [ __ ] or was it hidden it was hidden
from the kids but they did know so they
did see okay so the mom she worked as a
prostitute in that home so the kids they
would help book appointments for the my
god so they knew at least that much and
she also said this about her dad dad
used to say a father should break in
break his daughters in oh my firstborn
of a child oh wait the first born child
of a daughter should be her father's
from 11 to 12 he used to touch us all
the time if we put this way he would get
angry or say we were lesbians did he get
anything pregnant I don't know they
don't mention that I doubt it though
they don't this is some twisted Annie
well he wouldn't mind his wife being
like prostitute away like he probably
encouraged that yeah yeah
yeah I bet that's how they paid the rant
- what's craziest - this guy the worst
insult in the world is less yeah I know
you don't [ __ ] your dad your salt in the
world to him I want to be a lesbian or
your son to dance dick I know what the
[ __ ] that's crazy that's so backwards
yeah right and then so there are second
nuts also saying how so the way to
discover this is because in 1992 a
police officer was approached with
allegations that the parents were of
using these kids so then they were able
to get a search warrant they interviewed
the children and that's when they found
bodies like buried in the home bury in
the home early around the home oh and
they're just their siblings right no
just people it's it's women that so they
would they would kidnap these women or
lure them in or they would be
hitchhikers or they just different ways
of getting these women into their home
and once they were there they would
torture them and like a lot of them were
decapitated this I'm like surprised how
the kids didn't hear anything because I
was expecting torture screaming all that
stuff they probably did I mean they
don't clearly say that here but damn
didn't hear it so it must have been like
well what if they had like a special
torture room yeah weren't the whole
neighborhood had those bose
noise-canceling headphones they probably
did yeah both did a promotion on that
block and in the UK maybe there was a
Mexican family in that block and they
always have matcha music on and they
were playing fireworks at night yeah
that's a popular one next to a Filipino
family that liked to do karaoke every
single night so fireworks in our
neighborhood every single night it's
always around like skins are the
Filipinos I think it's Mexicans yeah
yeah my mom's leave her dad's too yeah
so this these are some photos so this is
Rosa day the mother damn Al Pacino
she was the prostitute who the [ __ ]
would pay for her
she'd have to line up a lot of a lot of
John's oh my god but he said del Toro
Jesus think he looks like someone he
looks like Andre the Giant yeah he looks
kinda like a gorilla yeah he does and
then these are the other kids this is me
you know when you see photos like this
though it's kind of crazy to imagine a
serial killer is like thinking oh I'm
gonna dress up my kids and [ __ ] take
pictures of them get ice cream and then
go home and beat and torture them for a
minute like it's so [ __ ] weird you
know that's twisted yeah and then like
maybe was also saying that like she
already cut ties with her mom but in the
beginning like well thank goodness she
would still visit her and like the mom
would write letters to her all the time
and not until after she was in prison
that's when she said that her mom
started telling her that she loved her
and like started saying like you know I
never knew or like I had no choice but
to let your father do all these things
but then May was like what the [ __ ] like
there's so many times especially Oh
because she would say I would have to go
along with his his [ __ ] because I didn't
want him to hurt you guys but then
that's when Mia was like well what what
happened when with Heather then yeah you
know he killed her so then she could
hide it there but crazy I love you and
it's crazy man because these stories
happen like a lot I mean like you hear
all these things about just a nightmare
that people grew up in and it's [ __ ]
nuts like just I think last week we did
one about the the the guy in Costa Rica
or whatever that killed somebody and he
had two sons and his sons witnessed it
is like [ __ ] dude can you imagine how
many other people are out there yeah
it's not nuts that they live like these
regular lives like they could be your
Walmart greeter they're bank teller they
already been killed you know that's how
I look at it they're saying that they
think he he might have heard this couple
meadows killed like about 30 people
god damn it is it like is it like is it
like an addiction
we're like they're like honey you know
what we haven't killed somebody in a
while I know that's his second wife by
the way they killed the first one and
then the first one so the first one I
guess he had like a daughter or like a
half like a stepdad or something and
then they're saying that they killed her
to the wife you know the daughters do
you think it becomes like one of those
things where you know like let's say you
have an argument with someone and then
you kill them in your life oh [ __ ]
problem solved and then that becomes
like you conditioned to always just do
this game black Miriam kind of did that
and this one episode where she like
which one it was the one where I can't
remember clearly but the point is like
the whole episode I think I was like
alligator crocodile or something that's
the name of it but she ends up killing
someone or she witnesses someone dying
and then leave years later on down the
line the person who ended up killing
that other person like he was like I
can't live with this anymore I gotta
tell somebody if she had like this whole
life built and it was gonna ruin her
life and then she ends up killing him
and then like that kind of spirals into
her killing other people because she's
trying to cover up all these other
murders and there's just like did you
guys see the black mare episode where
the girl made up a black man episode cuz
I just watched it I've seen every black
man I've never heard of that one are you
serious yeah the new season it's about
into the news and it's your fault
yeah I guess none hey don't come at me
GOI maman I'm Mariana healed my friend I
did watch the black mirror episode where
a guy thought a Blackmer episode didn't
exist I saw that one no but yeah that I
was so kind of really paint that up cuz
your end up getting in her own head and
you're like [ __ ] all of what you do like
this is crazy
I don't know I just started watching
that push I didn't finish it though way
like I got up the up and so whatever I
did see it was tight and we didn't
finish because someone was trying to
sleeping really bad off
happens to all marriages I swear to God
yeah TECA cuz me and Nikki are in Ozarks
right now and same [ __ ] happened last
night she fell asleep in the night
before that iPhone it's the one that
works out like works what I like is when
they don't like you better stay awake
for this one why don't you watch it
earlier no like you can't hold him while
you watch has a mind of his own
you are nuts well I forgot he's not a
tot like a baby baby anymore he's a
toddler now it's like chasing a rabid
dog all over the house he's like scaling
[ __ ] now right yeah quad and spider-man
he looks at blocks and he's like dope
this is my way out and then he tries to
climb or you like try some MacGyver some
[ __ ] and get off of the couch where he's
gonna [ __ ] break it right now when he
changes diapers like he'll grab the
ambient mint and he's trying to knock
the dad knows how to use tools I guess I
caught that tool like yeah so he's in
the Bronze Age right now yes
[Music]
[Music]